so i now want to turn to the question of
how to formulate our prediction problem
precisely
i want to be precise about how we're
defining the inputs and outputs of our
predictions
and that in turn is going to have
consequences for how we join the corpus
and the kb
uh how we construct negative examples
for our learning algorithms
and how we handle multi-label
classification
so first what is the input to our
prediction problem
in the supervised learning paradigm
the input is a pair of entity mentions
in the context of a specific sentence
we're trying to label a sentence just
like we do in part of speech tagging or
sentiment analysis
but in the distance supervision paradigm
we'll do things differently
the input will be a pair of entities
full stop
independent of any specific context
we're trying to determine the relation
between this entity and that entity
and that's it
the other question i want to look at is
what's the output of the prediction
problem are we trying to assign
a pair of entities to a single relation
that's called multi-class classification
or are we trying to assign a pair of
entities to multiple relations that's
called multi-label classification and
it's a different beast
so over the next couple of slides i want
to explore the consequences of these
choices
the the difference between these two
ways of thinking about the input becomes
really important when we talk about how
we're going to join
the corpus and the kb
in order to leverage the distance
supervision in paradigm we need to
connect those two we need to connect
information in the corpus with
information in the kb
and there's two different possibilities
depending on
how we formulate the prediction problem
depending on how we define the input to
the problem
if our problem is to classify a pair of
entity mentions
in a specific example in the corpus in a
specific sentence
then we can use the kb to provide the
label and this is what it looks like we
have a corpus example like this
we're trying to label this specific
example
and to do it we can check to see if
these two entities are related in the kb
yep they are and we can use that to
generate a label
for this example
labeling specific examples is how the
fully supervised paradigm
works so it's an obvious way to think
about leveraging distance supervision as
well
it can be made to work but it's not
actually the preferred approach if we do
it this way we'll be doing things
exactly as they're done in the
supervised paradigm
it does work but it's not the best way
to take advantage of the opportunity
that distance supervision creates
there's another way of doing things and
the other way is where instead we define
our problem
as classifying a pair of entities not
entity mentions in a specific sentence
but just entities elon musk and tesla
period
apart from any sentence
and if that's how we define the input to
our problem
then we can use the corpus
to provide a feature representation
that will be the input to the prediction
so if we have an entity pair like elon
musk and spacex
that we're considering adding to a
relation in the kb
we can find all sentences in the corpus
containing this pair of entities
and then we can use all of those
sentences to generate a feature
representation for this pair so in this
example i'm i'm imagining it doesn't
have to be this way but i'm imagining
that we're using a simple bag of words
feature representation
the bag of words has come from the
middle that is the phrase between the
two entity dimensions the blue phrases
here
and all i've done is counted up the
words
in all of these blue phrases
across
all of the examples in the corpus where
these two entities co-occur
um
and
yeah well you can see here in the in the
in the token counts that they include
tokens from the various examples
all of these examples together are used
to generate a single feature
representation this is a feature
representation for this pair
and it's this feature representation
that will that my that my
learned model will use to make the
prediction about this pair
so this is a very interesting way of
reversing things instead of using the kb
to generate a label to make a prediction
about a specific
uh pair of entity mentions in a specific
sentence i'm turning things around i'm
using the corpus
to generate a feature representation
that i will use to make a prediction
about an entity pair
in abstraction
an entity pair considered just as a pair
of entities
just one more thought on this um
this is still kind of about the topic of
joining the corpus and the kb we've
created a data set class which does that
which combines a corpus and a kb
uh it just kind of staples them together
and provides a variety of convenience
methods for the data set and one of
those convenience methods is this one
count examples
which shows for each relation
how many examples we have in the corpus
how many triples we have in the kb
and the ratio um so the
total number of examples the average
number of examples per triple
for most relations the total number of
examples is fairly large
so we can be optimistic about learning
which linguistic patterns express a
given relation i mean even the smallest
one has at least 1500
examples
that's not really you know industrial
grade
um
data but it's certainly enough for the
kind of exploration that we're doing
here
however for individual entity pairs the
number of examples is often quite low so
some of these relations are between some
of those some of these ratios are
between
one and two
of course
more data would be better
much better
but
more data could quickly become unwieldy
to work with in a notebook like this
especially if you're running on an
ordinary laptop
and this data is going to be enough to
allow us to have a fruitful
investigation
first i want to talk about negative
examples so by joining the corpus to the
kb we can get lots of positive examples
uh for each relation but we can't train
a classifier on positive examples alone
we're also going to need some negative
examples negative instances
so that is entity pairs that don't
belong to any relation
we can find such pairs by searching the
corpus for examples which contain
two entities which don't belong to any
relation in the kb
so we wrote some code to do this and
there are
a method on the dataset class called
find unrelated
and when we run it
wow it found almost 250 000
unrelated pairs
um
so 250 000 negative instances for our uh
for our prediction problem and that's
way more than the number of positive
instances if you remember the kb has 46
000 triples
each of those is basically a positive
instance it's something that we know is
definitely a positive example of the
relation
here we have 250 000 negative examples
it's so many more that when we train
models
we'll wind up down sampling the negative
instances substantially so that we have
a somewhat more balanced distribution
a reminder though
some of these supposedly negative
instances
may be
false negatives
they may be
entity pairs that don't appear to be
related
but in the real world actually are
our kb is not complete a pair of
entities might be related in real life
even if they don't appear together in a
kb and as i said earlier after all
that's the whole point that's the whole
reason we're doing relation extraction
is to find things that are true in real
life
um and true according to some text that
somebody wrote but aren't yet in our kb
okay now i'm going to come to the to the
to the question that was asked about
pairs that belong to multiple relations
and this this is uh related to the
question of the outputs of our
prediction problem
we wrote some code to check the kb
for entity pairs that belong to more
than one relation so that's this method
count relation combinations
and it turns out this is a really common
phenomenon in the kb there are lots of
pairs that belong to multiple relations
um for example i won't even mention the
the most common one but
there are 143 people in the kb
uh whose place of birth
is the same as their place of death
and actually that's not that surprising
right that makes perfect sense
um it even turns out that there's no
fewer than seven people
who married a sibling
well since lots of entity pairs belong
to more than one relation
we probably don't want to be forced to
predict a single relation
so this suggests formulating our problem
as multi-label classification we want
our models to be able to predict
multiple relations for any given entity
pair
there are a number of ways to approach
multi-label classification but the most
obvious is the binary relevance method
which just factors multi-label
classification
over n labels into n independent binary
classification problems one for each
label so if you have a pair like
pericles and athens you want to be able
to predict any combination of these
labels
you just train a separate model a
separate binary classifier
for each of the labels independently
each of them generates a prediction
independently
and in this example we've predicted that
the place of birth relation applies the
place of death relation applies but not
the has sibling relation
a disadvantage of this approach is that
it fails to
because it treats the binary
classification problems as independent
it fails to exploit correlations between
labels
for example there may well be a
correlation between the place of death
place of birth label and the place of
death label
and if you already have evidence
that the place of birth label applies
that might tilt you at least a little
bit toward saying yes for place of death
this approach of factoring them into
independent binary classification
problems uh is not able to take
advantage of that information
but it has the great virtue of
simplicity it's incredibly
straightforward incredibly easy to think
about and to implement
and
it'll suffice for our purposes it's
going to make the investigation
uh move move forward very smoothly
so
i want to sum up a little bit we set out
to
establish a precise formulation of our
prediction problem
and when we put all the pieces together
here's the problem formulation we've
arrived at the input to the prediction
will be
an entity pair
and a candidate relation
the output will be a boolean
indicating whether the entity pair
belongs to the relation
since a kb triple is precisely a
relation and a pair of entities we could
say equivalently that our prediction
problem amounts to
binary classification of kb triples
given a candidate kb triple like work
dat elon musk spacex do we predict that
it's valid
this is really nice because it's a very
simple way of thinking about
what problem we're taking on we have a
bunch of positive examples which come
from our kb
we have a bunch of negative examples
which we synthesize from the corpus
using pairs which co-occur in the corpus
but don't occur in the kb
now we have lots of data
consisting of candidate kb triples
including positive examples and negative
examples
we can use that data both for training
and for evaluation
and once we've trained a model to do
this binary classification we can now
consider novel kb triples which don't
appear anywhere in our data and ask
whether the model will predict them to
be true and by doing that we may
discover
new relations that are not currently
part of the the kb that could be
candidates for adding